nearly 75 years after the death of
gangster al capone some of his most
prized possessions are going up for sale
this friday capone's surviving
granddaughters held by weatherrails
auction house in california will sell
everything from weapons watches and
jewelry cbs sunday morning correspondent
lee cowan has the stories behind those
items and the controversy they're
stirring up
al capone was the cream of his crop
he was public enemy number one
he ruled the streets of chicago through
fear
during most of prohibition
and yet
the last known photo of al capone
is surprisingly gentle
taken a month before he died
it shows him embracing his wife mae and
his three granddaughters on christmas
day back in 1946.
diane capone was just three back then
she's 77 now
as we have lived all our lives my
sisters and i being very quiet about the
family and not talking about our
personal stories and prohibition marched
on leaving the ugly scars of violence in
its wake her grandfather was never
convicted of anything other than tax
evasion but not being convicted of
something doesn't always equate with
innocence it's widely believed capone
was behind the bloody saint valentine's
day massacre in chicago ruthless even by
mob standards
after that the mere mention of his name
or his nickname scarface was as icy as
chicago's wind
i can remember as a first grader
going out to the playground
and having people get off some of the
playground equipment because let's go
here's capone and you were how old then
i was six
to her al capone was only papa oh
there'll be a lot of dry throats in
chicago after this night's work by the
time diane was born capone was largely
out of business locked up in alcatraz
the rock
set aside for the worst of the worst
when he came back from
being in alcatraz he had gone through
quite a transformation he lived out the
rest of his life trying to make amends
trying to make peace with god and he
believed that he was given
a second chance
he lived out that second chance often in
loungewear at his florida mansion just
west of miami beach
when he died of a heart attack at only
48
his wife was so grief-stricken she
covered almost everything in the home
with bed sheets
it was full of old pictures fancy china
furniture whatever bling was called back
in the 1930s al capone
sure had a lot of it
this is uh just a regular tie clip that
well it's not just a regular
that's a pretty
[Laughter]
nearly 200 items including the more
provocative ones you might expect of a
gangster go on the auction block this
week
this gun was kind of his
protection
and i think it saved his life on a
number of occasions and so he called it
his sweetheart and he carried this with
him everywhere as far as i know yes
capone's semi-automatic colt is expected
to go for hundreds of thousands of
dollars it's
that part of his life the mob boss part
that intrigues people still
how do you square his two lives his
public persona as
a gangster
and his private persona as a grandfather
you know i can't
clearly he was capable of
compartmentalizing his life do you think
he was capable of murdering people
i i have no idea
that's not the capone she knew
this is
to my dear son
well son of my heart
here is dear father who loves you one of
the most personal items in the auction
is this handwritten letter capone wrote
to his son lyan's father while still
imprisoned in alcatraz
until next week give mother a nice big
kiss for me
and god bless you both
your dear father alfonse capone
and that is the person my grandmother
always knew he was she never gave up
hope no matter how heartfelt it may
sound
for some
the auction
is almost heartbreaking it's morally
sort of murky isn't it it is and i just
find it as very offensive to the crime
victims nina cerlano besselman is a
former california prosecutor she has no
connection to chicago or to capone but
she does have a connection to violence
her sister katina rose
was murdered in 1979
and ever since need has been fighting to
make sure it's victims who are
remembered
not the criminals and let's face it in
auctions for money if they truly want
people to know that he was a loving
grandfather truly wanted to know this
other side of him
then
put it in a museum we should not profit
off what i would call blood money you
know everybody's entitled to their own
opinion and i i understand that why some
people might feel that way i think we
all make mistakes in lives some people
make a lot bigger ones than others if
you could talk to people who may or may
not have been
victims of of your grandfather's
profession
what would you say to them
i don't know
i i i guess i would say i'm sorry
what diane capone has seen rummaging
around the ghosts of her family's past
is less about who al capone was
and more about who she says her
grandfather tried to become
even someone who has been
the kind of sinner that he might have
been the fact that he could confess and
try to make amends before his life ended
that that's kind of hopeful i think for
all of us
for cbs mornings i'm lee cowan
in sacramento
wow two very different points of view
there yeah
you know she's looking at it he was my
grandfather and then the prosecutor is
saying yeah but he caused a lot of pain
yeah a lot of damage america is
fascinated with gangsters yeah and what
you do on your worst day is not the
whole person i completely grant that but
pretty compelling evidence that yeah it
will make a lot of money off of that
auction that's for sure yeah they will
make some money